et terminer par accord avec des
syndicats représentatifs des entreprises
concernées nous proposons donc que cet
accord soit établi après consultation
des associations d'usagers agréé
signataires d'accords cadres avec le
cebs
il s'agit ainsi d' associer réellement
ces associations aux activités et aux
décisions du cebs
en l'occurrence à ses relations avec les
entreprises pharmaceutiques
vous l'aurez compris cet amendement
s'inscrit dans la logique de l'article
43 qu'un quiès prenant acte de la
décision de renforcer la démocratie
sanitaire
nous proposons de l'élargir turcologue
amendement 1013 madame archambault s'est
elle-même amendements prévus de la
commission le comité d'interface prévue
par l'article 43 15 pièces doit
permettre au président du cps de
présenter aux associations qui auront
signé un accord-cadre un bilan de
l'activité du cbs ce comité n'est pas
une instance permanente qui aurait
vocation à être consultés à chaque fois
que le cps signent une convention avec
un laboratoire c'est donc une demande de
retrait ou un avis défavorable sur les
deux amendements du gouvernement
oui c'est une demande de retrait
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices parce que votre amendement
vos amendements sont en réalité
satisfait au regard de l'article 43
qu'inquiets ce qui a été adopté qui
prévoit la création d'un accord cadre
entre le cep s et des représentants des
usagers
la mise en place d'un comité d'interface
qui n'a pas vocation uniquement à
recevoir un rapport une fois par an qui
a vocation à peser sur les orientations
être réunies régulièrement avoir des
débats avec les interlocuteurs donc la
demande que vous faites me semble sous
une forme différente de celle que vous
suggérez satisfaites par les
dispositions qui ont désormais été
adopté
merci oui madame archimbaud il est
retiré de vie de l'article 43
qu'inquiets ce n'est pas encore adoptée
nous semble-t-il il est en cours est en
phase d'être adoptée mais bon j'ai en
temps voilà j'entends les arguments
ça m'a mis le doute se madame la
ministre comme vous allez être vérifiée
mais non on est bien sur le terrain
trois qu'inquiets ce bon nous allons
retirer cet amendement puisque vous nous
dites qu'il est satisfait l'essentiel
étant qu'il fallait préciser ces points
là en séance publique
merci monsieur le collègue il est donc
retiré je suis saisi de deux amendements
identiques faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 812 monsieur
watrin oui l'article 43 qu'inquiets
spernot associations d'usagers de lutte
contre les inégalités santé de conclure
un accord cadre avec le comité
économique des produits de santé nous ne
pouvons que nous réjouir de cette mesure
qui permet à ces associations d'être
mieux informés des activités du comité
économique des produits de santé
activité sensible s'il en est puisqu'il
s'agit entre autres de fixer le prix des
médicaments et des dispositifs médicaux
la pression exercée par les laboratoires
et on le sert en effet à l'origine de
nombreuses suspicions de conflit
d'intérêts s'il est donc nécessaire que
les associations soient davantage
informés associés aux activités du cep s
il convient de faire en sorte qu'elle
puisse utiliser réellement ces nouvelles
prérogatives aussi nous proposons
d'accorder à ces associations un droit
de saisine des ministres de tutelle si
elle identifie des faits aux actions
dans la méconnaissance pourrait impacter
la politique économique du médicament il
s'agit donc ici de compléter le
dispositif de la loi sur les lanceurs
d'alert qui prévoit la possibilité pour
les associations de patients de se voir
reconnaître un pouvoir d' alerte ce
pouvoir concernerait dans ce cas les
associations signataires de l'accord
cadre avec le cep est merci mon cher
collègue et la parité ne marche un beau
pour le
12 oui c'est le même amendement avec le
avec la volonté de deux d'établir une
cohérence entre en effet la loi sur les
lanceurs dallaire qui a été adopté au
sénat l'initiative de marie christine
blandin et qui a prévu dans son texte
pour les associations de patients la
possibilité de se voir reconnaître un
pouvoir d' alerte ce qui constitue une
avancée importante donc cet amendement
complète le dispositif de cette loi de
santé au sein de l'article 43 kinks en
permettant aux associations signataires
de la torre de l'accord cadre avec le
cep de saisir les ministères de tutelle
si les identifie des faits ou des
actions dont la méconnaissance par est
impacté la politique économique du
médicament sur les accords conclus et
donc sur l'accès effectif aux produits
de santé pour les usagers du système de
santé donc l'amendement prévoit comme
l'a également expliquer ma collègue que
les suites données à ce droit dallaire
puisse être rendu public un avis de la
commission alors l'objet de l'article 43
qu'inquiets c'est d'améliorer la
confiance qui doit exister entre le cep
est ce donc chargé de déterminer à
politique de prix en matière de
médicaments et dispositifs publics alors
au contraire les deux amendements
présentés semblent partir d'un postulat
de défiance en prévoyant une procédure
de saisine des ministres là où l'accord
cadre doit permettre le dialogue
au demeurant les amendements transpose
les dispositions de la loi du 16 avril
2013 relatives au droit d alerte sans
tenir compte des différences importantes
qui existe entre les domaines de la
politique de l'environnement est
publique et de l'environnement et de la
politique économique du médicament dans
le domaine de la santé publique ou de
l'environnement
le fait même que le public mais
connaissent certaines informations comme
la nocivité ou la dangerosité d'un
produit peut en effet avoir des
conséquences sur la santé publique ou
sur l'environnement divulguer ces
informations permet donc d'éviter des
conséquences néfastes sont qu'une
intervention du public des pouvoirs
publics ne soit nécessaire
mais il n'en va pas de même aux yeux la
commission pour la politique économique
du médicament
en effet on voit mal comment la
divulgation au public d'une information
de nature médico économique est de
nature à impacter les politiques menées
ou les décisions par le cps qui a une
instance à vos questions techniques
par ailleurs les informations qu'elles
les associations susceptibles d'avoir
accès dans le cadre de leur dialogue
avec le cps sont par hypothèse connu des
pouvoirs publics
et ajoutons qu'une partie de ces
informations je l' ai déjà dit est
couverte par le secret des affaires
c'est donc une demande de retrait ou un
avis défavorable sur les deux amants a
eu des gouvernements mais ma vie ma vie
donc je mets aux voix ces amendements
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui et pour qui et contre 1
abstention ils ne sont pas adoptées je
me vois l'article 43 qu'inquiets ce qui
est pour et qui est contre
abstention il est adopté je mets aux
voix l'article 44 même volts
il est adopté nous en arrivons à
l'article 45 je suis saisi d'une demande
de parole de madame de roche rapporteur
donc nous arrivons à un article
important du texte et l'article 45 et
qui est relatif aux actions de groupe
les victimes d'une défaillance du
système de santé ont actuellement deux
voies de recours à leur disposition ils
peuvent engager une action individuelle
ils peuvent également s'inscrire dans
l'un des régimes spécifiques de
réparation des dommages médicaux au
titre la solidarité nationale avec une
procédure de recours amiable
or ces voies d'actions se sont révélés
peu adapté à la réparation des dommages
sérielle causés par la défectuosité ou
le mésusage des produits de santé comme
cela a pu être le cas dans le médiator
c'est dans le but de remédier à ces
insuffisances qu'il est proposé de
mettre en place une action gros par
matière de santé conçu sous réserve des
adaptations rendu nécessaire par la
nature corporelle des dommages en ville
indemnisés sur le modèle de l'action de
groupe en matière de consommation
alors cette action de groupe présente
quatre grandes caractéristiques en
premier lieu la procédure commune ne
pourra être engagée que par une
association agréée d'usagé du système de
santé qui jouera un rôle de filtre
ensuite cette action visera élargir la
responsabilité d'un produit de santé
dans la survenue de dommages sérielle de
nature exclusivement corporelle en
troisième lieu la procédure sera
articulée en deux phases la première
permettra d'établir la responsabilité de
l'exploitant ou du prestataire tandis
que la seconde visera à l'indemnisation
des victimes et à la réparation
individuelle des préjudices
enfin la phase de réparation des
préjudices pourra être amiable ou
contentieuse la commission des affaires
sociales a adopté neuf amendements cet
article dont 8 sur proposition de
monsieur andré reichardt rapporteur pour
avis au nom de la commission des lois
les principales modifications opérées au
terme des travaux de la commission sont
les suivantes
en premier lieu la qualité à agir dans
le cas d'une action de groupe en matière
de santé a été limité aux seules
associations d'usagers du système de
santé agréé au niveau national cette
limitation qui rapproche la zone groupe
en santé de celle qui existe en matière
de consommation permettra de donner les
meilleures chances de succès aux
requérants en s'assurant que les acteurs
qui porteront l'action groupe
disposeront l'expérience et des moyens
suffisants pour faire face à une
procédure souvent longue et complexe
en second lieu la commission a raccourci
de cinq à trois ans le délai maximum
pendant lequel l'adhésion groupe de
victimes est possible il s'agit ainsi de
limiter la durée de la situation
d'incertitude à laquelle sont exposés
les professionnels ce titre être
poursuivie sans pour autant léser les
droits des victimes
la commission enfin choisi de réserver
aux juges ayant statué sur la
responsabilité dans le cadre de la
première phase de l'action du groupe
la charge de se prononcer sur la
réparation individuelle des préjudices
lors de la deuxième phase il s'agit
ainsi de limiter les risques de
divergence d'appréciation d'une
juridiction à une autre ce qui pourrait
porter atteinte à l'égalité
justiciables voilà donc les équilibres
du texte qui vous est présentée par la
commission et sur lequel nous souhaitant
que nous souhaitons pouvoir garder
madame annie david s'étaient inscrits
une prise de parole sur l'article
oui merci monsieur le président notre
collègue rapporteure catherine de roche
vient de le rappeler cet article 45
ouvre la possibilité d'actions de groupe
initiée par des associations agrées
d'usagé du système de santé pour des
dommages subis du fait de produits de
santé défaillant cette possibilité est
nouvelle elle l'a rappelé je tiens à le
dire d'emblée c'est une avancée
indiscutable et qui mérite d'être salué
néanmoins nous regrettons son caractère
trop limité puisque la rédaction
actuelle exclu de l'action de groupe les
victimes d'autres préjudices sanitaires
et je pense en particulier à l'amiante
qui est un sujet particulièrement à nos
yeux
ainsi nous regrettons fortement que les
victimes de l'amiante soit exclu de ce
droit d'action de groupe
je pense également aux préjudices
d'origine environnementale qui tendent à
se développer là encore il est dommage
qu'il ne puisse intervenir du coup cette
limitation très stricte des possibilités
d'action de groupe réduit
considérablement la portée de l'avancé
même si celle ci reste évidemment
marquantes
vous avez dit à l'assemblée nationale
madame la ministre qui n'était pas
opportun d'étendre ce champ car se
poserait alors la question de la
possibilité d'une action de groupe sans
qu'il y ait manquements ou faute ou
responsables identifiés
nous estimons nous au contraire qu'il
est nécessaire d'ouvrir les actions de
groupe à ce domaine le plus rapidement
possible de la même manière nous
regrettons que cet article se limite à
la reconnaissance d'actions de groupes
pour les seules associations agréées
alors que les victimes pourraient
vouloir intervenir directement
pour cette raison nous avons déposé
plusieurs amendements concernant les
dommages sanitaires d'origine
environnementale et les préjudices
sanitaire suivies dans le cadre du
travail ainsi qu'un amendement visant à
permettre à plusieurs personnes victimes
de dommages causés par des produits de
santé défectueux de porter une action en
justice à l'encontre
un producteur d'un fournisseur ou d'un
prestataire via une association
d'usagers du système de sang de santé
agréé nous reviendrons donc plus
longuement dans le débat sur ces sujets
même si j'ai bien entendu madame la
rapporteure nous indiquait qu'au nom de
la commission le souhait était de
maintenir l'équilibré retrouvé
n'empêche que nous essaierons de vous
convaincre et de nous défendre ont en
tout cas nos amendements par l'état
monsieur daudigny merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mais chaque
collègue dans ce projet de loi la
démocratie sanitaire n'est pas un vain
mot ne tient pas de la formule ou de
l'affichage ce projet reconnaît
représentants des usagers une place
réelle dans l'élaboration de la
politique de santé et en force la
capacité des personnes à faire valoir
leurs droits en instaurant l'action de
groupe pour les victimes de produits de
santé cet article 45 constitue l'un des
aspects essentiels une approche globale
collective et solidaire de la réparation
des dommages qui peuvent résulter
l'administration de médicaments
elle est indispensable aux victimes
isolées sans moyens pour contrebalancer
des capacités judiciaires techniques et
financières des producteurs
je comprend donc mal les modifications
apportées par notre commission au texte
issu de l'assemblée nationale qui ont
pour objet à mon appréciation de réduire
les possibilités des victimes d'accéder
à l'action de groupe proposait en effet
de réduire le délai requis d'adhésion en
groupe de cinq à trois ans
reportage la rapporteure même le
rappeler est de limiter l'accès à cette
procédure aux seules associations
reconnues au niveau national sont autant
de restrictions apportées à
l'indemnisation des victimes
si j'approuve d'autant moins à
l'amendement qui entend supprimer ce
nouveau droit
je lui reconnais la qualité de la
franchise car en effet soit lent nan
mais la légitimité de l'action du groupe
et dans ce cas pourquoi multiplier les
entraves à son exercice soit on la
réfute
mais l'antre 2 que réalisent les
propositions de la commission ne sont
pas satisfaisantes
et ce d'autant moins que la commission
n'ignore pas qu'il ne suffit pas
d'adhérer au groupe pour être indemnisé
puisque il appartiendra encore au juge
bien sûr de remplir son office en
appréciant la réalité du dommage et le
lien de causalité
c'est pourquoi nous pour notre part nous
proposons la suppression de ces
restrictions à l'exercice de ce nouveau
droit je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue je suis saisi
d'un amendement 297 qui n'est pas
soutenue en arrivons à l'amendement 482
snm génisson qui le défend merci
monsieur le président est mon
intervention sera dans le droit fil de
ma collègue yves daudigny
en effet l'article 45 instaure l'action
de go dans le domaine de la santé une
procédure très attendu par les
associations d'usagers du système de
santé
ce type d'action doit permettre de
regrouper dans une seule procédure les
demandes de réparations concernant un
grand nombre de patients
cela constitue une avancée majeure
puisque les patients victimes avec cette
nouvelle voie de recours plus efficace
ne seront plus seuls face à la puissance
de certaines industries
la commission des affaires sociales a
adopté neuf amendements à cet article
dont la majorité à l'initiative de la
commission des lois
parmi ceux ci certains biens monsieur
denis vient de le dire restreignent la
portée de l'action de groupe
c'est pourquoi notre amendement vise à
rétablir en partie le dispositif initial
sur deux points particuliers
le premier point de concernant le
paragraphe 1 et le paragraphe 3 de
l'amendement ont pour objet de rétablir
la possibilité pour toute association
agrée de niveau régional ou de niveau
national de porter une action de groupe
en effet des axes des accidents sérielle
peuvent revêtir un caractère localiser
et les associations de victimes créé à
cette occasion au niveau local doivent
pouvoir conduire cette action le 2
rétabli la durée de cinq ans pour le dol
et l'adhésion au groupe des victimes
ce délai est plus favorable aux victimes
car il permet de prendre en compte la
longueur de manifestations pour
certaines conséquences des accidents
liés aux soins est le temps souvent
nécessaire à l'habitation des dommages à
une cause précise
merci monsieur avis de la commission
bon j'ai déjà exprimées dans
d'improbables ce qu'elle avait été
l'esprit dans lequel et la commission
des affaires sociales la commission des
lois avait travaillé sur cet article
donc ne serais pas surprise que donner
un avis défavorable
pourquoi on a choisi d'autoriser les
seules associations au niveau national
engagé une action de groupe c'est parce
que cela permet à nos yeux d'augmenter
les chances de succès des actions en
effet les associations agrées dispose
mieux que les associations locales de
moyens nécessaires d'expériences
suffisantes pour faire face aux
difficultés procédurales de l'action de
groupe en matière de santé qui je le
rappelle une action souvent complexe
longue coûteuse et que l'on met que l'on
met en place par cet article alors bien
sûr certaines associations peuvent être
constituées au niveau local pour
représenter les victimes d'accidents
localiser pour autant rien n'interdit à
ces associations d'intérêt des
associations nationales notamment des
collectifs d'associations qui
disposeront de moyens bien plus
important de meilleures chances de
succès en cas d'action groupe
cette adhésion est déjà est d'ores et
déjà une réalité
il suffit de regarder la composition du
collectif interassociatif sur la santé
le 6 alors quand au raccourcissement de
cinq à trois ans du délai d'adhésion la
commission avait considéré qu'il permet
de limiter la situation d'incertitude
d'une entreprise sur le risque auquel
est exposée mais sans pour autant léser
les victimes puisque celle ci
disposeront toujours en effet d'un dea
les conséquent trois ans et de la
possibilité par ailleurs d'engager une
action individuelle
c'est donc un avis défavorable un but du
gouvernement je donne un avis favorable
à cet amendement qui s'inscrit bien ou
inscrits bien là la logique de du
gouvernement pour l'action groupe je
note d'ailleurs que au fond il ya deux
points sur lesquels principaux sur
lesquels la commission a marqué une
différence significative par rapport au
projet du gouvernement sans s'en
remettre en cause son organisation et
ses objectifs ces deux points c'est la
question des associations agréées
susceptible d'engager lac son groupe et
c'est le délai dans lesquelles cette
action groupe peut être engagée le
premier point sur quelles associations
il y à des dommages qui interviennent
localement ou des accidents qui sont
très localisés
je vais vous donner des exemples très
connu epinal les irradiés d'epinal même
problème à toulouse il y a eu des
associations des structures locales
pourquoi demander à des structures
locales qui porte l enjeu local d'aller
adhérer à une structure nationale qui va
devenir à ce moment là une association
de principe et va rentrer dans
précisément ce que certains cherchent à
éviter c'est à dire des procédures
systématique qui seront toutes dupliquer
les unes par rapport aux autres donc et
y compris dans la sphère du médiateur
même s'il y a eu un problème il ya des
associations nationales il y a aussi des
associations avec des implantations
locales dans ce cas là je reconnais que
elles peuvent adhérer à une
confédération nationale puisque le
problème a été identifié partout sur le
territoire mais enfin
enfin tous les tous les dommages
n'apparaissent pas sur systématiquement
sur tout le territoire le deuxième sujet
c'est la durée pendant laquelle l'action
groupe est possible trois ans et ses
cours par rapport à la procédure
judiciaire engagée par rapport à la
prise de conscience par rapport aux
démarches individuelles qui peuvent être
réalisées puisqu'il ya un point de
départ qui est un jugement en
responsabilité de principe il faut qu'à
partir de là des individus réalisent
qu'ils sont dans le champ d'application
de ce jugement se rapproche des
associations prennent conscience des
dommages qu'ils ont eux même subi à
titre individuel et donc il me paraît
que cinq ans enfin il me paraît il nous
paraît après débat aussi avec la
chancellerie les structures juridiques
judiciaire habilités que le délai de 5
ans est un délai au fond raisonnable et
responsable en l'état monsieur reichardt
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des lois
oui maintenant la ministre le président
mes chers collègues
pourquoi se limiter aux associations
locales
c'est que pas bon oui pourquoi si vite
et aux actions locales alors qu aux
associations à laquelle locales alors
que manifestement dans un certain nombre
de cas dans la ministre celle ci n'en
n'auront pas les moyens n'auront pas les
moyens de mener au bout une action de
groupe ii pour avoir auditionné en
qualité de rapporteur de la commission
des lois
diverses associations celles ci n'ont
pas fait état de volonté exacerbée de de
jouer un premier rôle dans ce cas nous
pensons bien au contraire que le danger
avec une association locale se saisisse
la première d'un sujet que ce soit
déboutée et qu'ensuite on ferme la porte
à toute action future
vous parliez tout à l'heure de
d'adaptation meilleure adaptation d'une
association locale à un sujet local vous
avez cité la sphère des zirides y ait
des irradiés d'epinal même dans une
affaire comme celle-ci il est tout à
fait envisageable qu'une association
locale face engagé l'action par la
structure nationale à laquelle se
rattachent ne voyons pas pourquoi à
partir du moment où il y a comme vous le
savez plus de 100 associations
nationales contre 400 associations
locales il ne puisse pas y avoir un
rattachement à cet égard sur le
rétablissement du délai de cinq ans nous
pensons que ce délai n'est pas
souhaitable pour deux raisons la
première c'est qu'on prolongerait et
nous y sommes naturellement très
attentif
longtemps la situation d'incertitude
s'agissant d'une exposition aux risques
contentieux bien sûr dans laquelle
l'entreprise défenderesse seraient
placés nous pensons qu'il faut trouver
un équilibre raisonnable entre les
droits ouverts par l'action de groupe et
naturellement la nécessité pour une
entreprise de ne pas vivre une situation
que j'ai qualifiée tout à l'heure
d'incertitudes trop longue et une
deuxième raison me paraît tenir aux
avancées permises par les amendements de
commissions nous vous avez pu le voir et
nous le diront encore dans le débat nous
avons modifié la rédaction du texte pour
autoriser l'engagement d'une nouvelle
action de groupe lorsqu'elle ne porte
pas sur la réparation des mêmes
préjudices qu'une action précédente
et ça c'est quand même fondamental ceci
permettra notamment à des victimes de
seconde génération de profiter d'une
telle action
je pense en particulier au cas des
victimes de distilbène est donc
voilà nous pensons que la mesure où il
est possible d'engager une deuxième
action group il n'est pas nécessaire de
prolonger de façon trop longue la
possibilité d'engager l'action groupe
par l'état madame ghoul et c'est tant
mieux mais chers collègues moi j'ai vice
président et avec le président françois
autain et chantal jouanno la commission
d enquête sur le médiator et je dois
dire que tout ce qui peut restreindre
l'action groupe me gêne un peu parce que
je pense que cette action pour laquelle
on montre tellement de frilosité est
tellement attendu par les victimes
tout à leur collègue annie david parlait
de l'amiante s'il ya bien un problème
qu'on connaît dans l'orne et dans le
calvados avec la vallée de la mort c'est
le problème de l'amiante il ya encore
des salariés de moulinex ils sont
toujours pas indemnisés et s'il ya bien
un problème qui est local c'est ce
problème là et je pense que lorsqu'on
parle d'incertitude pour les entreprises
moi je voulais parler d'incertitude pour
les victimes
et donc là il ya quand même un vrai
problème quand vous avez des gens qui
est temps de dix ou quinze ans la prise
en charge de lors de leurs problèmes
médicaux donc moi je voterai je veux
très très volontiers l'amendement 480,2
pour toutes ces raisons je suis
extrêmement hostile à l'idée de
restreindre l'accès au groupe par l'état
monsieur bourquin pour réputation de
vote
rip sur cette question je pense que nous
avons avec cet article 45 une
modernisation très importante du système
de santé parce que dans la grande partie
des pays d'europe aux états unis il y à
l'action de groupe et le malade le
consommateur ne se retrouve pas seul
devant un grand groupe
comment pharmaceutique et il y à là
proposé par la ministre
quelque chose de très important nous
arrivons à ce moment de l'article 45 on
pourrait sous-estimer ce qui se passe ce
qui se passe là est très important et la
demande de réparation plutôt que de
laisser la personne seule devant le
groupe
il y à une action de groupe qui est
proposé il y a l'action de groupe à la
française qui est sauvegardé avec la
possibilité d'avoir accès à une
association et le débat que nous avons
c'était savoir si on le limitent à des
organisations nationales où nous prenons
en compte les les comment les
associations régionales
hélas comme l'a dit la ministre tout à
l'heure on a des problèmes de santé qui
sont parfois très régionalisé et combien
le dire ma collec tout à l'heure cette
innovation
on ne doit pas la limiter bien au
contraire il faut lui donner toute son
ampleur quand on sait les problèmes que
nous avons rencontrés on as it et tout à
l'heure mais la donne sur le médiator et
d'autre on a besoin que les malades
puissent se défendre et puissent accéder
à l'action de groupe et c'est pour cela
que je trouve que cet amendement